I'm watching I'm watching the tape
Brothers have this I guess Rumble show
and then Steve will do in a six and out
of there and the two brothers are trying
to talk about like the misperceptions of
of misogyny and all this other [__] yes
there are some ideological [__] six nine
was so drunk bro and he's just like
hugging Steve will do it and then hey
brother trying to be like listen it's
it's unfair for a man to be treated in a
way he was like whatever man
it is
it's not it's our serious around someone
being silly no no I think my boy don't
do it right now he just got out of a
four-year relationship who six nine oh
he's no longer with that girl he and his
girl just are now show only fans man no
no you know the pain you feel no no no
you break up with her today tomorrow she
got lipstick written on her ass cheeks
oh my yo catch me only fans no though
man I I think with him
he was one of the most entertaining
people
on the planet man I I don't even know
that
what what what what what I mean I feel a
little disappointed by him but like we
talk about it do you want more music
from him or you're disappointed that
he's kind of like removed himself from
public life no he's not removed from
public life he's just removed from the
cultural conversation so in rap yeah so
he's not like you could probably say
he's not a musician at the moment right
right but you'll see more than a lot of
Steve will do with videos which he's
still a Creator yeah because he's
creating content but it's just that you
know that's not the stuff and I think he
I think he he he's starting to realize
you you can't be six nine of YouTube you
have to be six nine in music and culture
what do you mean by that you can't be
explosive and control conversations like
conversation starts in the culture then
trickle elsewhere the reason why Steve
will do it wanted to meet you
is because you were a phenomenon in rap
you were a figure and somebody who
people were marveling at you can't do
that on YouTube just doing Vlogs it
ain't gonna happen you know I mean but I
think you know that's interesting he's
gotten to the point though
which I think this is an interesting
point he could always make like he just
went to Russia picked up 350 000 to
perform old songs
somebody paid him a hundred thousand
just to play FIFA with him just because
he's a spectacle still so
he won't go broke
um well that well that will dry up
eventually that way yeah that does dry
up why they're not streaming for him is
that it's a dumb idea because it seems
like he's so good at at engaging he's
just streaming yeah
it's easy you all could collaborate make
some crazy [__] together we'll just say
his music career is done
um for the last couple times he came out
didn't really
hit no
but it's this label are you crying son
what do you mean no it's a label hey yo
hey yo yo it's a label that was crazy
bro come on man yo that is cute
hey no no I'm gonna tell you why'd you
say throat around us
that his label say that [__] on top of
your shoulders
so he's not getting playlist
he won't get playlisted and they're
looking at him like
make it hot why can't his label do get
him on playlist
can you explain Black Bolt
so
I mean because I heard Tori Tori talking
about this yeah nobody's gonna really
talk about like how I do also did Tori
shoot Megan [__] I don't know what why
isn't he in jail if he did I'm like so
how's yours left oh is he he slapped the
rapper he slapped him for a while oh
yeah August oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and
we back okay look you you made a really
astute observation before we had to go
pee about six nine in about a week man
son but we're not out here streaming
like you know historically we're
streaming other ways
yeah well okay
I want to get to this I want to get to
this because you made an interesting
point which is like yeah the way that
six nine could affect culture through
music and the music culture itself so if
it wasn't just putting out music it was
like antagonizing these artists he's not
able to do the same thing through
YouTube for some reason why is that Hey
listen
um music is just so much more powerful
than but there are people who can affect
culture through YouTube
um that's just their platform
okay show comes out on YouTube okay but
but Joe Rogan is is off play the six
nine as a vlogger is not six nine as a
rapper
which means he won't demand the same
crowd to the same audience I see I see
it there's not as much desire to see
yeah talk [__] to rappers no so music is
just completely different it's the
reason why usually when a rapper gets at
me I gotta go ten times as hard as them
because you know for example let's get
back to a little baby he dissed me on a
song or two songs that's on an album
that's gonna be probably streamed if you
look at the stats 200 million times so
you got to go every single day you get
what I mean like that his the
amplification and also he said it he's
always said a line I got to do like a
five hour live stream breaking him down
and that line is gonna be so memorable
it's gonna stick in culture you know
what I mean it's gonna be me more this
is interesting so this is why you feel
like you've got to go so hard because
it's the only way to combat the only
penis of music but that's why I look at
you know as an artist you just have the
club Vibe and all of a sudden a line
distance yeah
yeah back to back exactly that is a is a
popular diss track so now you just at a
restaurant you're at [__] Chipotle or
whatever and then all of a sudden
there's a bar dissing you I see why you
have to return the energy in such a wild
way and that's why I look at six nine
and I'm like well you know there's
always two ways to to you know make
money you could live off the past or you
could keep forging away
until he returns to music he's living
off the past I don't care what he does
content-wise
he'll never he'll never make any
any Big Splash in the vlogging world
that he um because what he did in music
was unique and new yeah so he has to do
something unique and new in the vlogging
world because you're saying right now
what he's just living off of is hey I
was that artist that's now vlogging yeah
exactly so yeah I would say for six nine
I don't know any six nine the name of a
six nine song but I know six nine and
part of it was he was beefing with
rappers which seems like to lames like
me such a high-stakes game like you're
playing with your life you're bragging
about snitching that's why that's why I
go back and forth you know some
YouTubers who call me out recently I
think I had them on here oh two things
I've been preached I love Auburn
preaching I was like yes I'm like yo
listen hello I wish my brother's the
best but I ain't got time Kanye just
mentioned me little baby's a Dismount
his album yeah I'm gonna get to y'all
that's like that's like a two-day beef
this [__] for the last one it's that's
how the the population you got to watch
this stuff though they're excellent yeah
they're like you like they're gonna
charge it up if somebody goes at them
and says somebody does whatever they're
gonna go for it they're good guys you
know yeah what they do no no they're
good guys and they they do I want you
guys to get along I hope y'all know how
to beat no no no no no I mean I would
like I didn't even watch the video
because like if I watch if I consume any
content that I don't that I have an
opinion about the moment this Hennessy
touches my lips I'm going off so I
didn't watch it like I still haven't
watched it the only thing is I gotta
titled it and this was someone we were
just talking about even um off of this
[__] like they were
lumping me into like they cover this
particular part of YouTube about mana's
fear and rent pill and alpha male yeah
and all of a sudden they were like yo
this alpha male academics and I'm like
yo who talks like that yeah yeah he's
like I'm alpha male yeah you know what I
mean it's stupid hey not because I call
myself big act because that's just what
happens in music yeah like big Draco
like Draco the first one to do it he
says big Draco all right so if it's big
Draco all right it's big act or big
everybody big Theta you used to call
yourself big baby a big blue pill
I don't even like that blue pill red
pill [__] it's like I used to be a
little blue pill
I feel all that stuff is like you know
kind of overblown because it's ideology
you know and and it's been getting
popular recently because people want
Something to Believe In to get out of
their current state but like I'm not
somebody who subscribes to either of
those things some of these things might
match with what my already thinking is
but also some of them some of those like
you know thoughts or some of those
ideologies is like you are completely
reject so you know I see them kind of
like label me like I was like in the ilk
or realm of fresh and fit and fresh and
fit on my homies but that's not
necessarily me so like once I see that
I'm like you know I I know they do
reaction videos and they they do usually
pretty fair critique I'm not gonna get
at them
um just because I feel like
they didn't understand they're thinking
I'm something that I'm not uh so you're
giving them benefits because usually
they're being honest and they're
shooting from him also I think they also
when they saw the video
again I don't know how much research
they did they said the way they titled
it I didn't watch it they titled it like
I put my hands on a woman which at that
point we're not even keeping it
intellectually honest uh right and you
know that's something what that by shade
room posted initially that's what some
people thought right so so when I seen
that I'm like you know what
just because I don't want to go back and
forth to try and I get really nasty and
low down or come to get at somebody I'm
like I'm gonna just let you have I never
look at it but yeah yeah so like
situations like that I'm not tripping
over that though right I said I like
going back and forth with rappers when a
rapper put me in a bar or when Mega
stallion tweet at me you forever putting
in me history
like they're almost seeing the people
who I've interacted with that's why I
like going back and forth remember
actually
is heightened my profile I can't go to
somebody like you you know who those
dudes are I've been preacher I can't go
I can't go to the club like yo y'all
know I've been preach made a video about
me like what the [__] yeah yeah the
[__] I played here 30 times a night I
remember twice on this album yeah you
know what I mean the mom and I thought
Charlemagne made it made it it was when
Drake put him in back to back I was like
this [__] is gonna pop bottles
of sharks he's a part of history now
facts like that's crazy fact so and it
just shows you where influence and
culture kind of comes from because like
even even like people who are way bigger
than me on YouTube they'll just they'll
look at me in a in a completely cool
unique space because they're like yo
you're in the realm of this RAP
Community that we all like people look
up to music musicians like they're
streamers this guy Kyson that ADA Ross
they're bigger than some of these
rappers there's rappers talking to them
just to try to get a platform yeah but
it's not seen as cool as some of these
rappers yeah you know what I mean
there's a cool factor to music yeah
they're rock stars and right now
streamers are not rock stars yeah and
who knows what they will be in the
future but at this moment they're not
there's something about music also music
Just Hits you differently it's
biological like us there's a reason why
like you teach the ABCs to kids in a
song it just hits us diff true right
like and that's why I said six nine
gotta get back to it you gotta get back
to the [__] that really matters unless
you're you know I know you said the
money's gonna drive but he should be
good for a while yeah um if you're just
good with getting booked to perform show
uh songs from a couple years ago cool
but if you wanna you know me I came in
this to be a legend the tricky thing
about six nine is that like I'll be
honest the most fire six nine song which
one
in my opinion he wasn't beefing with
nobody which one [__] got that wet work
got that what was it good but that [__]
with it was Nikki was on assault like
for me
I thought to me that's the one yeah
that's the most fire well he's on the
stoop with all the Bloods yeah that was
the hottest sauce is what he's beefing
let's see shots
knowing that it's almost like come on
what no no